you know one of my favorite teams what
against is gonna walk out there to talk
about the skydiving the car true through
power is the helicopter my personal
favorite is the bathroom raw I think
it's just you know it not only is it
great because it's Ethan hunts very
vulnerable in that scene there's also a
badass role when you look at that scene
what makes that scene work is how hard
the actors are working it was wild and
it took a very long time to shoot a very
long time going back and readjusting
stuff then going back again and
readjusting more stuff that big set
piece where I throw liang through you
had to get it right because that's a
huge reset if i got it one step wrong i
had to then pause halfway through and
hold him where he was so it doesn't end
up being 40 minutes a two-hour reset
because I messed it up so a lot of a lot
of pressure to get it right but amazing
choreography by wolfies david and
eastwood actually starts team kicking
ass and getting your ass kicked his
heart they both ways all of us none of
us walked away from that scene going we
were all limping trust me it was and
none of us would admit it by the way not
one of us would ever admit it
you kind of shake your arms and you get
ready to punch they were like he's
reloading his arms yeah cognizant of
that was what was the note they're like
what was that move it was just something
that kind of came to me gonna happen
August Walker is he's a tough guy and
he's not used to losing fights and so
he's an enormous E frustrated that stage
so that's his right pubs are off I'm not
gonna try and protect you now who's
gonna beat the living daylights out of
you a lot of times the camera and the
editing have to do the work for the
actors to create that energy but you had
Liang Yang who's the guy in the bathroom
they've been fighting henry cavill
extremely dedicated and Tom Cruise
obviously you're not gonna find anybody
better one of the great things about the
scene is he's not afraid to make himself
look older yeah it's not afraid to get
hit get knocked down all of those things
contribute to what makes that scene self
on it and it let me sit back and not
have to do so much cutting and shaky
camera
[Music]
you